قالت ام بي سي نقلا عن ماسولين امريكيين
ان مسؤوله غرفه الدردشه جاك تكسيرا
والمشتبه فيه بتسريب وثائق البنتاجون
السريه هذا ونقلت صحيفه جورنال عن مسئولنا
امريكيا قولهن المحققين يعتقدون ان تسريب
وثائق مزعومه شديده السريه من المحتمل ان
يكون مصدره احد افراد الحرس الوطني الجوي
الذي كان مقره في فورت براق وقت التسريب
وانه ربما يعتقل اليوم
عرف اسم هذا الشخص المسؤول عن تسريب هذه
الوثائق السريه هل من تبعات لذلك نريد
تفاصيل لو سمحت
بالتاكيد طبعا الان اصبحت
عفوا بالتاكيد الان اصبحت الامور اكثر
وضوحا من قبل ضاقت بالفعل الدائره حول
المتهم بالتسريب لكن تبقى كل هذه
المعلومات هي معلومات عبر وسائل الاعلام
الامريكيه لم يصدر بيان رسمي حتى هذه
اللحظه او لم تصدر تصريحات من قبل
المسؤولين الامريكيين لكن يمكن القول ان
هذا المشتبه به الان باتت التهابات واضحا
لدى اجهزه الامنه الامريكيه والتحقيق الذي
قال عنه الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن تحقيقا
شاملا ستعلن نتائجه قريبا على ما يبدو
كانت لديه كل هذه المعلومات امر اعتقال قد
يصدر ربما اليوم باعتقال جاك تكسيرا وهو
مدير هذه المجموعه مجموعه الدردشه التي
الذي تشير اليه اصابع الاتهام جاك تكسيره
مدير مجموعه الدردشه وايضا
بدء التحقيقات الموسعه حول حمايه امن
المعلومات الامريكيه اعتقال هذا الشخص او
تحديد المشتبه به ليس هو نهايه التحقيقات
ولكنه بدايه هذه التحقيقات وسائل الاعلام
الامريكيه تتحدث ايضا عن ان هذه المعلومات
وهذه التسريبات لم تصل الى
امور اكثر حساسيه او اكثر خطوره ولكنها
تتعلق بمعلومات
تخص
وسائل دفاعيه اكثر منها
سياسيه وبالتالي هي ما زالت قيد التحقيق
من جانب وزاره العدل ووزاره الدفاع
الامريكيه
كانت منتشره على الانترنت
منذ حوالي شهر وهناك
عتب الان وتحقيق في كيف انها انتشرت على
الانترنت لمده شهر ولم يتم التبليغ عن ذلك
بالفعل جمال يعني طبعا هناك معلومات
تتسرب حول ان هذه المعلومات بالفعل موجوده
على شبكه الانترنت منذ فتره طويله لكن لم
تنتبه اليها اجهزه الامن الامريكيه
ربما بعدما بدا الحديث حول دور هذه
الوثائق وتاثيرها على الحرب الروسيه في
اوكرانيا وبدات تتفاعل على الساحه الدوليه
بدات اجهزه الامن الامريكيه تنتبه الى هذه
التسريبات وبدات التحقيقات للوصول الى
المسرب او من يقف وراء تسريب هذه الوثائق
شديده الاهميه وايضا عندما بدات لجان
الدفاع في مجلس النواب وغيرها من المؤسسات
الامريكيه تتحدث عن ان هذه التسريبات تشكل
انتهاكا خطيرا لخصوصيه وامن المعل
الامريكيه وايضا تؤثر على علاقات الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه بشركائها وتؤثر ايضا
على امن وسلامه القوات الامريكيه حول
العالم خاصه في اوكرانيا حيث اعترف
مسؤولون امريكيون بالامس بان هناك عسكريون
امريكيون في السفاره الامريكيه في كييف
رغم انهم اكدوا ان هذا هذه القوات
الموجوده في السفاره وهؤلاء العسكريين
الموجودين في السفاره الامريكيه في كييف
لا يقومون باي نشاط عسكري ولكنهم فقط
لمتطلبات التامين واجراءات التامين فقط